honestly it is weird you don't seem to
age
i feel awful on the inside
greatly when we first met i looked
younger and now i think i've surpa i
could be his father
to be fair though seth when we met you
were 15 and you look like you were 37. i
did
i was like 20 years old
but even because often when people grow
beer well clearly i do but you know they
are gray or have gray in them but even
yours beautiful beautiful beer thank you
thank you well i'll start with coming a
little bit right there oh please and
actually we've got a picture of you at
kansas university i don't know how old
you were here look how beautiful you are
as you can see i don't just grow hair on
my face
look how happy you are i remember taking
that picture and uh i worked on my hair
i worked on it
i was uh i was greatly inspired by
michael hutchins who was my hero at the
time and i think i tried to blow it dry
and it came off looking a little more
bon jovi than i
anticipated there's a whiff of julia
roberts off you wouldn't
just beautiful just
beautiful in that picture
[Music]